وسط حاله من الاستغراب والاستنكار احيانا
اخرى بين الاهالي قررت سيده مصريه ترشح
لمنصب عمده قريه تابعه لمحافظه المنوفيه
منصبه ارتبط تاريخيا بالرجال فقط لكن
دكتوره ساره زهران الاستاذ الجامعي قررت
خوب هذه التجربه في البدايه عرضتها
عائلتها وطلبتها بالتعقل لكنها شرحت لهم
حرصها على تقديم العون لاهالي قريتها انا
الدكتوره ساره عبد الرحمن زهران مرشح منصب
العبوديه بقريه ابو الشابه مركز مركز
السادات محافظه المنوفيه هل يتقبل المجتمع
ان تكوني ملجا لرجال المنطقه في ظل
الثقافه الذكريه السائده
الحمد لله متقبلين الموقف متقبلين الموضوع
كله همم
بنسبه 90% اما الباقي فهما مش معرضين ان
انا كشخص هم معارضني همم انا دلوقت ان انا
اوعيهم واعرفهم اني منصب العمده حاليا ما
عادش بين الصوره اللي كانت بتبينها اللي
همم السينما المصريه او اللي كان قبل كده
منصب العمده حاليا همم هو همم يعني همم
وظيفه ايه اداريه ايوه اي نعم هو بيبقى
على راس السلطه التنفيذيه ولكن منصب
العمده دلوقت همم في تحت من ايده او معه
يعني على جنب الى جنبك
شخصيا لماذا قررت التقدم لهذا المنصب قلت
انه برنامجك سيكون خارج او تفكير في خارج
الصندوق كيف دكتور حدثنا اكثر
اولا انا دارسه تخطيط وسياسه كليه خدمه
اجتماعيه جامعه حلوان دائما قناه الاخصائي
الاجتماعي
من خلال دراستي انا شايفه ان انا عندي
كثير جدا من المشكلات اللي انا ممكن اتغلب
عليها
من خلال استخدام الموارد والامكانيات في
المجتمع سواء كان الشباب او عقولهم او
سواعدنا احنا همم جميعا في القريه فان شاء
الله بامر الله تعالى ناويه لان البرنامج
بتاعي يكون فيه اا يعني في جانب ثاني
لوظيفه العمده مش بس الجانب الامن او
الجانب الاجتماعي بفضل المنازعات ولكن
يكون في جانب عنوان تنوي مهم جدا يمكن من
خلاله ان انا انهض بقريتي وانا باهل بلدي
يعني من صوره افضل منها
يعني بصراحه هل تعتبرين انه حضورك كبيره
هذه المره لتكون عمده المنوفيه
بصراحه انا عندي ثقه كبيره جدا في القياده
السياسيه وفي القياده الامنيه في المنوفيه
ان هم يدوني الفرصه اني انا اثبت وجهه
نظري واثبت نفسي واقول ان الست تقدر تقي
مجال حتى لو كان مجال يعني بيلخص يدور
عليها ان هي تدخل